The Witcher 3 released one year ago now
here we are in 2016 and the final
expansion blood and wine is coming soon
we've got a ton of details and a release
date i'm tony and this gamespot news
update comes from the peaceful land of
two salts blood and wine hits ps4 xbox
one and pc on May 31st developers CD
Projekt RED says it's 90 new quests will
add more than 30 hours of gameplay
Darrell condec himself out with 100 new
pieces of armor and more than 30 new
weapons while he battles over 20 new
monsters that's a lot of numbers and
here are two more the new game plus
maximum level is increasing to 100 and
you can unlock 12 new mutations and if
you're a fan of Gwent you'll be able to
duel with the new Skellig a deck now
that's what I call an expansion sweatin
wine is the witcher 3 second and final
expansion after last fall's hearts of
stone it'll cost you 20 bucks by itself
or you can get both expansions for 25
for a more in-depth preview of all blood
and wine has to offer you can visit us
at gamespot but for all the latest in
RPGs DLC and other three-letter acronyms
you're already in the right place
you